I was so excited to see you this weekend
we're looking for Brandon aren't you
excited buddy yeah never worn II broke
my arm no man that time I dared you to
eat candle remember that time you always
bottled up your feelings at that time
that you were yeah maybe you should cool
it with the snacks how's that supposed
to mean as your sister gained a little
weight
hey now you're gonna have kids one day
you're gonna be going to the PTA and
buying braces and you think wow how did
this happen it happens believe it
Oh in ten years honey you won't have
enough energy for children you want to
do it now hey brick Oh Brenda Brittany
Brandon Pitts Brittany
I mean Oh Brandon by the way actually
Brittany put that on here so she knows
about yeah you're gonna want to ask her
I click I click this we're done so
remember the mouse this is the mouse now
that's one ounce this is the bass snap
mom so you have to clean our bathroom
did she say that what did she tell you
to you're stupid
[Music]
what's so funny oh you're disgusting our
neighbor is doing it again
[ __ ] yeah okay your pores look weird
today I just want to say that you two
are the cutest couple Oh actually
remember that one time we drank a puddle
yeah you made me drink a puddle just
second
[Music]
remember that time you told grandma you
hated her stay still
Jackie the groom I was being a [ __ ]
that day